police discovered an unexpected twist in
the murder of a well-known hairdresser
Beauty executive Fabio Simon Tilly was
stabbed at his pool last year two
suspects were caught on home
surveillance video but their identities
were hidden the killers were thought to
be part of a notorious group of home
invaders targeting Hollywood celebrities
Michelle Miller shows us the evidence
that transformed the case here's a
preview of her 48 hours report new
surveillance video knock-knock burglars
caught in the act so this is LAPD
footage yeah they know what they're
doing and they know what they want gangs
of the so-called knock knock burglars
have wreaked havoc in wealthy Los
Angeles neighborhoods for several years
since January at least seven celebrities
had hundreds of thousands of dollars
worth of jewelry taken high profile
victims include $300,000 from former
Laker star Derek Fisher $175,000 for
Nicki Minaj and 2 million from Alanis
Morissette's Brentwood home but back in
January of 2017 they were linked with a
murder for the first time Fabio Simon
Tilly was a famous hairdresser and
Beauty executive welcome everybody fab
here for another table style Friday
Bobbi was bigger than life in the
industry I love it he was the iconic guy
the International hairdresser that came
to the US it's beautiful he mentored so
many people I was so proud of him Fabio
had worked with his sister Marella
establishing themselves on a global
stage and his wife Monica and their kids
saw the benefits including a beautiful
home in Los Angeles the house that
Monica wanted my queen he called her she
loved it because it had a huge kitchen
she said that he would come home drop
his bags sweep her off her feet and
dance with her detectives search them
until he's home for evidence of what led
to his death detectives were hoping
there would be a surveillance video
to help them solve Fabio's murder and
there was a neighbor of Fabio's had a
sophisticated surveillance system you
can see two men jogging towards Fabio's
house and 35 minutes later leaving with
his Porsche but to their surprise it
wasn't a break-in gone wrong that killed
Fabio it was something much darker alien
DNA would break this case wide open and
months after the murder a pair of
arrests which shocked
just about everyone we're here to
announce the arrest of two individuals
in connection with a murder of Fabio
Sinan Tilly I'm Mike you sure that was a
huge shock I was absolutely shocked
there wasn't a red flag it was like a
twist in a in a nightmare oK you've got
us all hooked now Michelle Miller is
here with more how important was a
surveillance footage okay it was key now
keep in mind that the surveillance video
you just saw was a neighbor's
surveillance camera Fabio had a very
sophisticated system but they could not
find it it was stolen so whoever stole
it and committed the murder knew exactly
where to find it it was hidden in the
garage that's one thing the second thing
was access to that video was on a cell
phone and depending on who had that
access broke this case wide open and
tell us about the two arrested in the
case you know I can't tell you too much
but one of the men arrested was one of
the men who was running in that video
away from the home okay we'll definitely
be watching that Michelle thank you
you're welcome
and you can see Michelle's full report
who killed Fabio tomorrow night on 48
hours it airs at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS